[Música]
en Primera Plana
Carlos Serrano
Bienvenidos a en primera plano un
programa de radio Francia internacional
y de France 24 esta semana volvemos a
poner el foco aquí en Francia porque los
sindicatos endurecen su pulso contra
macron por la reforma de las pensiones
nos acompañan en este estudio Antonio
Delgado corresponsal de Radio Nacional
de España en Francia bienvenido Carlos
Gracias encantado Florencia Ángeles
corresponsal de la W radio del grupo
prisa en Colombia bienvenida Gracias
políticas en la universidad de edimburgo
y asociado en seanspo aquí en París
bienvenido Muchas gracias Un pulso
interminable entre macron y los
sindicatos que prometendurecerse a
partir de la próxima semana hoy nuestro
asunto en Primera Plana
[Música]
los sindicatos amenazan con paralizar
Francia a partir del mar de 7 de marzo
si macron no echa marcha atrás con su
controvertida reforma de las pensiones
que recordemos pretende retrasar la edad
de jubilación de los 62 a los 64 años y
aumentar a 43 la exigencia para poder
cobrar una pensión completa llevamos Ya
varias movilizaciones masivas en las
calles desde enero que han expuesto una
Unión sindical que no se veía desde
tiempos de Nicolás sarcosí el gobierno
no se ha echado atrás y ahora entramos
en lo que podríamos denominar una fase 2
de endurecimiento de un pulso que ya
podemos decir que es el gran asunto que
marca este curso político aquí en
Francia y muy probablemente lo que le
quede a macron en el segundo mandato
repasemos algunas portadas que nos deja
la prensa a diario El Fígaro El
Ejecutivo no cede pese a la movilización
en las calles dice el diario conservador
que las líneas de uno y otro bando
parecen casi inamovibles una reforma que
llega al senado ahora donde el jefe de
filas los republicanos Bruno retalló
dice en entrevista con lepac yan que es
un texto necesario pero insuficiente
recordemos que macron quiere apoyarse en
la derecha moderada para sacar adelante
la reforma el diario Liberación Afirma
en esta portada que aún más que las
pensiones es la inflación y su coste
social lo que más teme macron en esto es
en estos momentos bueno Antonio tienen
tiene la impresión de que pasamos a esa
segunda fase a partir de esta semana
podríamos hablar de una fase 2 de un
endurecimiento del pulso de los
sindicatos en la calle absolutamente yo
diría Incluso un poco más creo que
llegamos al combate final a la lucha
final no Por decirlo en términos
marxistas que no sé si nos valen o no
para definir la situación actual pero en
cierto modo Sí sí llegamos al momento
decisivo porque por un lado llegamos a
la fase definitiva de la tramitación
parlamentaria de la Reforma el texto
está en el senado luego habría un comité
mixto para que volviera a la asamblea
nacional pero estamos por una cuestión
de calendario y de procedimiento en la
fase definitiva esto se tiene que
aprobar o no en cuestión de un mes y a
la vez el pulso de los sindicatos por la
misma razón tiene que manifestarse ahora
en toda su amplitud es ahora cuando se
va a ganar o se va a perder la batalla
creo yo En cuestión de las próximas
semanas y ese combate definitivo el
silbido inicial se da el martes con la
el inicio de la huelga convocada por los
sindicatos
bueno a partir del día 7 los sindicados
llaman a paralizar Francia se elige esta
fecha porque es bueno cuando han acabado
las vacaciones de invierno Florencia hay
síntomas de que alguna de las líneas
pueda moverse Por alguno de los dos
lados pesará más la erosión de la
protesta o la presión sobre el ejecutivo
qué líneas se moverá por el momento
ninguna o sea de entrada los sindicatos
han dicho que ellos no van a regular
digamos a retroceder Mejor dicho en esta
cuestión de la edad no que ellos
mientras el gobierno no se separe de 64
años ellos van a seguir protestando y
van a seguir justamente con las huelgas
y el gobierno al final también dice que
para ellos no hay marcha atrás en ese
proyecto de reforma Entonces por el
momento al menos por el momento
se va a mover de hecho como decía
también Antonio esta semana para mí esta
es la semana también decisiva el mes
efectivamente no porque también está la
discusión en el senado y luego regresa a
la asamblea nacional del proyecto pero
el sindicato o los sindicatos Mejor
dicho en esta semana van a intentar
justamente que toda la fuerza de las
calles salga para que pues al ejecutivo
lo orienten digamos hacer algún cambio
El Ejecutivo Por el momento no ha dicho
en estos últimos días se ha mostrado un
poco
a la expectativa de lo que justamente va
a salir en movilización y en huelgas la
próxima semana recordando que llaman a
huelgas reconductibles cada día a las
seis de la tarde van a votar las
acciones para el día siguiente y Bueno
yo creo que va a ser después esta semana
que quizá el gobierno vea cómo cambia
Quizá no la ley pero la estrategia no la
estrategia que a lo mejor de desviar
hacia otros focos hacia otros temas y no
solamente la reforma de pensiones para
poder avanzar un poco más en su
estrategia ahora vamos a hablar de esos
otros focos la movilización es en la
calle han sido masivas pero el
porcentaje de huelguistas así que bueno
ha ido decreciendo en lo que hemos visto
de las jornadas convocadas en enero y
luego en el mes de febrero durante
vacaciones un periodo de vacaciones
invernal que hemos tenido ahora bueno
las cosas se han quedado un poco
congeladas los sindicatos llamaban a que
no hubiera huelgas en el transportes
para seguir manteniendo digamos el apoyo
de la opinión pública que ahora mismo
parece esencial no O sea totalmente o
sea yo creo que la estrategia de los
sindicatos ha sido bastante buena han
mantenido la unidad han encontrado muy
bien los tiempos intentan no cansar
demasiado a los manifestantes al mismo
tiempo que los mantienen activos durante
todo el tiempo el problema es que las
movilizaciones
no se mantienen únicamente por el cabreo
que hay por una situación dada que en
este caso es clarísimo sino por las
expectativas de Victoria no solo te
movilizas porque te cabrea algo sino
porque esperas conseguir algo a través
de esa movilizaciones y aquí creo que el
problema más que estratégico es un
problema institucional que tiene el país
de Francia que es una sociedad un poco
el gobierno un poco sensible a las
demandas ciudadanas y esto creo que es
el problema que vamos a ir viendo a
largo plazo como mientras expectativas
no vayamos viendo que ser posibles que
se abra una brecha va a ir decayendo
quizá posiblemente el movimiento y es
aquí donde macron espera jugar el juego
de largo plazo el precedente de algo
parecido a lo que podemos ver estos días
se trata de 1995 cuando el gobierno del
Primer Ministro conservador fue Alan
jupe por entonces dio marcha atrás con
su reforma tras una huelga feroz de tres
semanas creo recordar de los transportes
no sé si este episodio es el que está en
el retrovisor ahora mismo de los
franceses Aunque la sociedad lógicamente
ha cambiado no estamos en el 95 Antonio
Probablemente sí y todo el historial yo
creo de protestas en materia de las
pensiones se cita menos pero en el año
67 Perdón por la erudición de Wikipedia
hubo ya una gran protesta contra un
cambio en el sistema de las pensiones
que Entonces planteaba el gobierno de
pompidou y que fue un poco el precedente
de la revuelta después del 68 en el
sentido de que hubo una Unión que ahora
también se intenta entre lo que es el
sindicalismo puro y duro o la lucha
Obrera con los estudiantes que ahora
también están teniendo un papel muy muy
relevante en las manifestaciones yo creo
que sí que el 5 habrá quien mire también
aunque se ha tratado de evitar ese
precedente a los chalecos amarillos una
duda que tenemos hasta ahora lo
comentaba antes Javier y también
Florencia las manifestaciones han sido
multitudinarias y en los sondeos quedan
muy claro que él un porcentaje altísimo
de franceses está en contra pero la
creciendo además incluso ha ido
creciendo pero es una evidencia también
que macrón ASUME ese coste político él
sabe que la batalla de la opinión
pública la ha perdido y que su intención
es aplicarlo porque cree que el tiempo
acabará abandonar la razón y está
dispuesto a asumir el coste político de
aprobar una reforma impopular Entonces
ahora El dilema que se plantea para los
sindicatos es Cómo hacer que el coste
sea tan alto que el gobierno o quemacron
decida dar marcha atrás y la duda es si
esto pasa por endurecer la protesta
desde luego con huelgas pero vamos a
asistir a una cierta
evocación de lo que ocurrió con los
chalecos amarillos yo no lo sé pero creo
que la tentación está ahí Y que en el
debate de Los sindicatos también
probablemente esté ahí no por parte de
los sindicatos como dice Antonio macron
sigue defendiendo su reforma la última
vez ha sido en el salón de la
agricultura allí dijo el presidente que
no hay ningún milagro todos sabemos que
vivimos más y si queremos preservar el
sistema de reparto debemos trabajar más
parece claro que el desenlace de este
capítulo Florencia Javier va a marcar el
legado de macronosis están de acuerdo si
aquí el legado histórico lo que pasa la
historia va a depender mucho de este
capítulo exactamente sobre todo porque a
ver se está ya en su segundo mandato O
sea ya no puede reelegirse no es
realmente es algo que para él la
incredibilidad también política Aunque
quizá también le cueste que en
popularidad que ya tuvo cinco puntos a
la baja en este último mes justamente
después de de la Reforma de pensiones
pero para él es lo que se juega no es su
credibilidad es la propuesta de campaña
también más sonada y bueno quizá lo que
decía hace rato no quizá va a intentar
que la gente también se dé cuenta en
otros aspectos para que esta reforma
pueda salir adelante no no es la única
reforma que está proponiendo de hecho
muy interesante también que casi a la
par de la Reforma de pensiones bueno
unas semanas después salió la reforma
también otro otro tema muy espinoso
digamos en Francia que es la reforma a
la migración no Y también en eso se ha
intentado poner un poco el acento el
acento en las cuestiones de salud y el
acento en el poder de compra no Entonces
yo creo que que sí se lava la va a
apostar y no tendría Nada que perder
digamos porque finalmente es lo que a la
apuesta en su segunda mandato Javier
elegado de macrón sí totalmente yo creo
además están elevando el tono ayer Vimos
a Olivia el portal del gobierno hablar
de que parar Francia ya llegando al
ridículo para Francia iba a implicar no
tener cuidado de la salud de los de los
niños o que iba a provocar una crisis
ecológica es decir creo que están
claramente elevando el tono que macron
asumido el coste político clarísimamente
que además tiene un sistema en el que la
cultura francesa además no tiene tanto
no tiene tanto la negociación tiene un
conflicto bastante importante entre
entre lo que suele ser el gobierno que
suele ser más de derechas y los
sindicatos y la movilización social a
diferencia de otros países por ejemplo
Suecia este tipo de reformas llevaron
siete años de negociación para reformas
que se dieron 98 y en el 2017 es decir
es una cultura política distinta y que
macron ASUME tranquilamente que macron
está cómodo en esta pelea y que por
tanto no ha apostado demasiado Como para
como para echarse atrás Ahora si miramos
a la oposición A quién puede beneficiar
y perjudicar políticamente todo este
interminable proceso de reforma y voces
sindicales Antonio que denuncian que la
adopción del texto provocará una
desesperanza social y quizá aupará la
extrema derecha cuanto menos es
verosímil el diagnóstico Sí el
diagnóstico es verosímil y la pregunta
es muy buena y yo el problema es que no
tiene una respuesta fácil no el foco en
la oposición política ahora mismo lo
tiene la izquierda para la extrema
derecha es un debate complicado porque
por un lado efectivamente Ellos están en
contra de la Reforma no no van a darle
ese caramelo a macron pero posicionan en
la calle con los sindicatos no
efectivamente Porque además en el debate
tal y como lo quiere plantear macron
también según el cual este es una lucha
entre quienes defienden la cultura del
frente a otros que en su opinión serían
perezosos o visto desde el lado de la
izquierda entre una lucha entre el
capitalismo despiadado y quienes
plantean que debemos ir no hacia otros
tipo de sistema de las relaciones
económicas y laborales que pasen más por
el ocio por la semana de cuatro días en
ese debate que se está configurando y
que parece un poco volviendo a terma
marxista la dialéctica nueva no en la
que estamos entrando en Francia y no
solo en Francia en ese debate la extrema
derecha en el fondo está más cerca de
creo yo de macrón que de la izquierda
Entonces
es difícil que a ella le beneficie lo
que pasa es que a largo plazo la
alternativa si miramos sobre todo las
últimas presidenciales la alternativa
real al macroismo parece más le pen
Entonces es difícil medir Qué puede
ocurrir Cuando esto cuando llegue la
hora de pasar cuentas que es queda
todavía un tiempo en 2027 a quien puede
acabar beneficiando no en cualquier caso
parece lejano que la izquierda o no esa
sensación de que pueda sacar rédito
político de esta situación lo cual para
hacernos muchas preguntas sobre todo
también ahorita la extrema izquierda ha
quedado muy mal con el debate en la
asamblea nacional no O sea la Francia en
sumisa quedó realmente vapuleada tanto
por los mismos partidos de izquierda
como incluso los sindicatos que dijeron
No vamos a hacer el circo otra vez o no
vas a querer en ese circo Y ahorita
también interesante que por ejemplo en
el senado si viene izquierda ya también
ya presentó según yo tres mil la
reservas no es la izquierda de Ecología
de ecologistas y de socialistas la
Francia sumisa ahí no está no y quieren
que sea un debate más productivo sobre
esa lógica de trabajar más para mantener
el sistema que está en el corazón de
todo lo que está pasando en Francia
vamos a hablar a vuelta de pausa
ampliando el zoom y hablando de las
consecuencias y de las derivas que puede
tener este tipo de debate sobre el
trabajo en nuestras sociedades
occidentales será la vuelta
[Música]
Enlace del cono Sur a Norteamérica de
los Andes a Centroamérica una cita
semanal con los temas más importantes de
los países del continente americano
presentada por los corresponsales de
France 24
enlace en France 24 y France 24.com
sabe cómo identificarlas acompáñenos 24
vea como distinguir entre información y
contenido falso en las redes sociales
desinformando una herramienta para
verificar y contextualizar información
es información certificada todos los
días en todas nuestras emisiones
[Música]
seguimos en Primera Plana esta semana
hablando de la Reforma de las pensiones
Y de esa segunda fase a la que se
aproxima el debate con el endurecimiento
del pulso de los sindicatos en las
calles lo hacemos con los periodistas
Antonio delgado y Florencia Ángeles y
con Javier carbonel doctorando en
políticas de la Universidad de edimburgo
y asociado en París macron ha vuelto a
justificar Hace unos días la Reforma
apoyándose en el argumento base a mayor
esperanza de vida necesitamos más años
cotizados para hacer el sistema
sostenible Javier Por qué cada vez más
franceses rechazan mayoritariamente está
lógica aparente del argumento
gubernamental Claro porque no se está
proponiendo la idea un digamos un
proyecto de sangre sobre lágrimas por
utilizar la palabra la frase de
churchelle para que luego veamos una
reforma que esa sala de forma definitiva
y que a través de esto ya salvaremos las
pensiones en realidad lo que se está
diciendo y lo que tenemos todo el mundo
claro Es que después de reforma
seguramente en cinco años veamos otra y
luego en 10 años veamos otra se propone
sangre sobre lágrimas Para proponer
luego más sangre más sudor y más
lágrimas entonces Es lógico que las
personas obviamente defiendan los
derechos sociales que han conquistado y
que se opongan a esta lógica de
perderlos continuamente hemos analizado
en la primera parte del programa lo más
factual vamos a ampliar ahora el zoom
para intentar ver lo que trasciende a la
reforma les pregunto Florencia Antonio
Javier es un debate planteado en
términos del sistema actual hablamos de
edad de jubilación de años de trabajados
cotizados etcétera Pero que no tiene en
cuenta quizá nuevos parámetros que cada
vez más asoman o que se tienen en cuenta
para poner en cuestión el rol del
trabajo en nuestras vidas no se están de
acuerdo que a lo mejor es un debate
planteado en términos que hasta antes de
la pre pandémicos no sé cómo lo
podríamos Llamar Antonio Yo creo que esa
es una pregunta también fundamental no Y
además relacionado con lo que
mencionabas antes no Por qué la gente no
acepta o gran parte del pueblo francés
no acepta esa lógica que parece
imbatible de macron de hay que trabajar
más porque si no el sistema no se
aguanta decía Javier y creo que tiene
razón porque piensan que esto es sería
una derrota sin fin y cada apretarían
más las tuercas pero para mí la duda es
por qué se ha aceptado tan fácil
entonces en el resto de Europa en España
en Alemania en Italia y en Francia no no
que es lo que hace Francia distinta no y
hay razones muy diversas no incluso casi
metafísicas sobre la relación entre
francés y el trabajo pero lo que yo creo
que aquí está emergiendo es un poco lo
que tú planteas no empieza a ver una
lógica empieza a abrirse en el debate
político de una manera más o menos
solvente la alternativa a la lógica
neoliberal de Tenemos que trabajar
siempre más la única vía para progresar
es esforzarnos más empieza a surgir como
alternativa política no sé si sería o no
No sé si cuajará pero sí que se va
oyendo cada vez más lave discursos que
dicen no se puede trabajar menos no
Quizá no hay que crecer siempre tanto no
podemos Buscar otras vías de desarrollo
económico y social Esto hace no sé si es
la pandemia lo que lo cambió o la crisis
de 2008 pero creo que antes sonaba
y ahora y ahora empieza a sonar cada vez
más en el debate político en Francia y
creo que no solo en Francia no y ahí es
donde está la batalla y por eso esta
batalla es interesante una de las
explicaciones a lo que dice Antonio
visto desde fuera podría ser la alergia
de los franceses A las reformas no sé si
este argumento explica todo lo que
estamos viendo o no O se queda escaso
Pues yo creo que a ver es un hecho que
al francés le gusta manifestarse no y
siempre está sobre todo con un derecho
tan arraigado como el derecho a la
pensión no Entonces es una lógica en el
ADN creo que está siempre esta cuestión
de de ir en contra de cuestionar y de
rechazar que lejos de tener más derechos
se les quiten no y y también lo que
decía Antonio Serrato no O sea
finalmente se ha cambiado mucho en
cuanto a la sociedad también quizá de
consumo no O sea ahora ya estamos no en
el proceso sino también en decir a ver
tengo que tener un trabajo que me
permita también tener una vida personal
un poco más equilibrada vamos a decir
entre trabajo lo de la semana de cuatro
días también va por eso y
exactamente y finalmente en la pandemia
pues se vio mucho eso no de que no
tienes que estar presente no haciendo
horas en el trabajo frente al computador
para ser productivo no O sea puedes
estar en tu casa trabajando lidiando con
otras cuestiones y finalmente se cambia
esta perspectiva de una oficina que
tienes que estar de ocho a ocho no de
cinco días a la semana entonces también
creo que la gente dicho a ver hizo todas
las las este generaciones jóvenes son
las nuevas generaciones están realmente
mucho en esta cuestión del equilibrio
Así que también eso ha impactado en este
momento Si yo creo que sobre todo el la
evolución ha venido no tanto de un
cambio de mentalidad de las personas
como un cambio en el trabajo el problema
es que la lógica de todo el sistema es
que tú trabajas y se te paga decir que
el trabajo paga y el gran problema es
que esto es lo que no está sucediendo
desde hace 40 años lo vemos aumentar la
desigualdad y vemos que cada vez los
costes de la vida cuestan más y el
trabajo y el salario no es suficiente
para cubrir las necesidades y tener una
vida buena como como se tenía como se
tenía antes entonces Es lógico que hemos
vivido un momento en los últimos años en
los que tanto las perspectiva más
neoliberal de que hay que trabajar más
quiero ser millonario esta idea del lobo
de Wall Street pero también ha habido un
discurso de tienes que dedicarte a lo
que te apasiona tienes que cambiar el
mundo tienes que hacer algo útil y te
identificas Por así decirlo con tu
trabajo que al final lo que ha provocado
en muchos casos es que aceptemos en
Muchos trabajos en el mundo de la moda
el mundo del periodismo el mundo de
marketing trabajos precarios trabajos
freelance trabajos que realmente no no
pagan tanto como como deberían claros al
final estamos en un momento en el que
nos damos que es que el trabajo no paga
que es que no compensa todo este
esfuerzo
para para el resultado que tenemos luego
creo que es sobre todo cambios en el
trabajo lo que ha provocado el cambio
cultural más que más que la otra forma
claro entonces este choque por la
reforma de las pensiones que lo vemos lo
más factura en la calle evidencia un
debate que como están viendo más
profundo filosófico podríamos decir y
social sobre el rol del trabajo en
nuestras vidas es decir al final sí que
hablamos de retraso de la jubilación
hablamos de estos términos pero el
trasfondo de este debate tiene
implicaciones que van más allá no de
años de cotización y de edad de
jubilación totalmente yo creo que este
debate es interesante al parte de por el
follón que se ha armado porque reúne las
dos visiones ahora mismo en conflicto en
Francia y además yo creo que macron
también lo sabe Y por eso él enarbola el
estandarte de la cultura del trabajo él
quiere él quiere venderlo como nosotros
somos la Francia que se esfuerza más y
para esforzarse más y para poder mirar
en este futuro de economía Global en la
que tenemos que competir hay que
trabajar más él aplica esa lógica y lo
aplica no solo porque crea que las
cuentas salen en el sistema de pensiones
sino porque piensa que esa es su apuesta
política y que el tiempo acabará dándole
la razón a ese discurso político y lo
que estamos viendo lo que está cuajando
de alguna forma en esta en este debate
concreto sobre dos años más en la edad
de jubilación es la aparición de un
discurso alternativo que se está que no
pasa por ahí que pasa por opciones de
crecimiento económico por opciones de
ocio que efectivamente todo eso enraiza
también en la cultura económica política
de Francia
anterior pero que en el fondo lo que
está es plasmando el gran debate
político no solo aquí también el cambio
climático por ejemplo sin ir más lejos
no también hay quien plantea que el
cambio climático hay que resolverlo
buscando un crecimiento económico más
moderado no eso es lo que está
apareciendo aquí y eso es lo que hace yo
creo interesante el debate como una
especie de cruce de caminos en el que
Francia va a salir en una dirección o en
otra no otro ejemplo el tiempo libre
como parte del valor social añadido y no
como mero tiempo de consumo llenar
nuestro tiempo libre de cultura de
acción social de tejido social de
diferentes tipos de ocio y no solo
puramente consumista esta vuelta de
tuerca es muy no se podríamos decir
antisistema si antisistema en el sentido
de que no se ha considerado lo
suficiente en este tipo de debates sobre
la reforma de las pensiones es decir
siempre se nos ha expuesto el tiempo
libre como un tiempo de consumo
y de hecho ahora también algo que se
había dicho recientemente en algunos
debates sobre qué tanto estaba
consumiendo la sociedad y a que ahora
habían ahorrado más los franceses No
justamente es ahora porque ya no compran
por ejemplo no sé incluso las ofertas
hubo también una baja en las ofertas de
invierno últimamente y decían es que ya
se están viendo más hacia quizás hacia
viajes o hacia quizá comprar o intentar
comprar una propiedad No ya no es tanto
como el el día a día no
una cosa que hay que entender es que la
por ejemplo la jornada de 5 días no que
es una conquista social que se hace a
través de movilizaciones también tiene
que ver con el desarrollo de la economía
del momento en el que tú tenías un
sistema de manufactura de empresas que
están produciendo muchos coches El
problema es que tú necesitas
consumidores necesitabas que Esos
trabajadores tuviesen tiempo libre para
disfrutar de ese ocio y poder consumir y
comprar y al mismo tiempo tuviesen
salarios relativamente altos para poder
consumir todo lo que se estaba
produciendo el cambio El problema es que
el cambio económico que estaba en los
últimos años es distinto ahora
consumimos mucho más servicios Ahora hay
consumidores en todo el mundo con la
internacionalización
internacionalización de la economía no
sólo tienes que buscar consumidores en
tu pueblo o en tu ciudad o cerca de tu
casa y ahora mismo lo que gran parte de
las empresas especialmente las
tecnológicas lo que producen son datos
no tienen consumidores tienen usuarios
que les producen datos y que luego les
venden a otras compañías para poder
vender los productos muy muy muy muy muy
muy digamos
especializados para para ese tipo de
público entonces claro a este tipo de
economía este tipo de empresa el
trabajador ya no es un trabajador y
consumidor es puramente un trabajador y
los costes del trabajo son simplemente
costes no se ven como algo que sea una
inversión luego en Consumo Y esto es
parte del programa que está produciendo
la la búsqueda obviamente de estar todo
el rato trabajando y la precarización de
las de las condiciones laborales Antonio
Florencia Javier todo lo que estamos
hablando hoy Qué importancia le dan al
factor pandémico es decir la pandemia ha
influido en estas nuevas perspectivas y
consideraciones que hoy estamos teniendo
en este debate
puede haber influido en la medida en que
haya roto también ese paradigma según el
cual la única alternativa en esta
economía globalizada era esforzarnos
cada vez más porque si no van a venir
economías emergentes China India Brasil
donde los costes laborales son más bajos
y nos van a quitar el puesto de trabajo
Esa esa idea de alguna forma yo no sé si
ha sido derrotada me parece demasiado
decir eso pero se está agrietando se
está agrietando ahora Estamos viendo una
especie de repliegue
Incluso en Francia lo vemos de manera
muy evidente con renacionalización de
empresas está viendo una
desglobalización es decir mucho pero
está en cuestión esa idea entonces en
esa medida yo creo que influye también
en el debate de las pensiones ya no todo
el mundo compra a lo mejor están
equivocados pero ya no todo el mundo
compra la idea de que la única
alternativa para sobrevivir en este
futuro competido es trabajar más no hay
gente que plantea alternativas yo creo
que sí ha tenido un impacto en la vida y
en este concepto de del trabajo no el
sentido justamente Antes estabas
haciendo planes a largo plazo con la
certeza entre comillas de que se y
cuando llega la pandemia y te das cuenta
de que bueno Por una parte no la la
gente cercana que que fallece y que
tenía sus planes y bueno y otra parte
también la gente que decía bueno a ver
mis planes de salir de vacaciones a x
lado pues se fueron Porque tuvimos este
este encierro no y después también te te
pones a pensar Okay a ver he trabajado
tanto para tener No sé a lo mejor vivir
en París donde el centro de París te das
cuenta que en el encierro a lo mejor el
centro de París no es lo mejor porque no
puede salir No tienes esta esta visión
de un apartamento o una casa en el campo
donde tengas más más posibilidad de
respirar no Entonces yo creo que sí ha
cambiado en muchas cuestiones el
pensamiento que tenemos hacia lo que
queremos y justamente Si queremos
pasarnosla trabajando o las 24 horas del
día no Javier en cualquier caso y aún
aprobándola está reforma Abre una brecha
grande entre macron y los franceses En
qué puede apoyarse el presidente a
partir de ahora para reconducir su
popularidad en lo que le quede de
segundo mandato Cómo solventar esa
brecha pues o sea yo creo que tienes
razón con la con la división yo creo que
lo que vemos es que en general la
sociedad cada vez demanda más protección
social y una intervención un poco más
fuerte del estado y en ese sentido
macron se le puede calificar como como
el último neoliberal Por así decirlo el
último presidente que realmente defiende
una posición liberal que en otros países
se está moviendo más hacia una
intervención más fuerte del estado que
yo no estaba protector que que no encaja
bien con macron yo creo que lo que él
espera lo que él está jugando es a dejar
pasar el tiempo en otras por desgracia
en otros países en otros países cuando
van estas reformas también se han visto
manifestaciones pero al pasar el tiempo
el señor aceptando poco a poco y son muy
pocos los países que han vuelto atrás
con muchas de estas reformas de
pensiones únicamente los que han visto
crecer las tasas de pobreza Entonces al
final la sociedad por desgracia acaba
aceptando esto pero por eso me parece
fundamental movilización constante pues
muchísimas gracias a los tres me quedo
ya sin tiempo para más Antonio Delgado
Florencia Ángeles Javier carbonel
Muchísimas gracias ha sido muy
interesante y a todos ustedes les
esperamos aquí la próxima semana en
Primera Plana Muchas gracias
[Música]